le parole sono importanti ci mettono in
relazione danno forma al nostro pensiero
le parole della nostra lingua
sono straordinarie sono sonore evocative
ricche sono piene di storie di
vibrazioni di emozione sono sonore sono
evocative risuonano con la nostra storia
e di bellezza della nostra lingua e del
fatto che questa bellezza vada tutelata
preservata percepita nuovamente vi
parlerò vi parlerò della marea montante
dell'it anglese la mescolanza
provinciale immotivata spesso oscura di
parole italiane inglesi che da pochi
anni sta cominciando a diventare comune
ma la prenderò un po alla larga e
comincerò a mostrarvi alcuni motti
latini hanno molti latini sulle loro
insegne le maggiori università del mondo
e li mostrano un grande orgoglio
qui siamo in australia qui siamo a hong
kong e c'è un motto latino nel ghana in
corea in russia in svezia nel regno
unito al king's college di londra e nel
regno unito a oxford a chicago negli
stati uniti harvard dice veritas nella
sua insegna non solo le università
orgogliosamente dichiarano se stesse in
latino londra ha un motto latino parigi
ha un motto latino il canada ha un motto
latino il queensland in australia ha un
motto latino ma non solo
la marina americana dice sempre in
fileni se l'avete sentito sempre il film
in mille fili
la merita la marina britannica parallel
latino e perfino un'istituzione non
certo nota per essere passatista come la
nasa regala un motto latino alle
missioni apollo perché la sto facendo
così lunga con il latino e con i motti
latini perché se c'è un singolo posto al
mondo in cui un motto latino ci poteva
stare
è questa eccolo la culla del latino
avete visto invece qual è il recente
marchio turistico della città di roma
approvato lanciato dalla dalla
municipalità romana è questo
non si capisce neanche cosa come
dobbiamo pronunciarlo miu miu cos'è
questo ammiccamento di bassa lega
cos'è questa contaminazione questo corto
circuito tra due lingue che toglie il
senso ciascuna cosa sono quelle cinque
palle in alto
e uno si chiede ma perché
ma perché nel momento in cui guardia se
guardiamo tutti i marchi turistici tutte
le città del mondo non c'è nessuno che
faccia la cosa insensata di storpiare il
suo nome per promuoversi da nessuna
parte sono a roma ma proposito i suoi
pià tour e vogliamo dare un'occhiata al
portale turistico
appena lanciato dal ministero dei beni
culturali bello pronto
cioè non molto bello very beautiful
colla siamo italiana inglese in maniera
del tutto insensata non piace a noi non
piace neanche gli anglofoni la cosa
curiosa è questa ma lui steel speak
italian parliamo ancora italiano voglio
sto parlando dell'italiano la lingua più
romantica del mondo a proposito di nuovo
mi ha spezzato la lingua più romantica
del mondo
secondo a320 linguisti anglosassone la
quarta lingua più studiata al mondo ai
non studiano l'italiano per fare affari
lo studio perché lo amano per la cucina
per la moda per l'opera per l'arte per
la storia per dante lo studiano per
questo stiamo parlando stiamo parlando
nella lingua degli angeli
secondo thomas mann
eppure ecco per esempio la pizza ha
conquistato il mondo continuando a
chiamare pizza qui vedete la mappa delle
pizzerie negli stati uniti confrontata
con la mappa dei negozi con la quantità
della stessa mappa dei negozi che
vendono hamburger hot dog vince la pizza
ecco se tutto il mondo mangia e dice
pizza perché noi qui in italia beviamo
wine
guardate qua mangiamo food e beviamo
wine a lucca cernobbio catania a milano
e la cosa è curioso perché a new york
se al waldorf astoria devono promuovere
la settimana del vino italiano di
corvino
perché i ristoranti di new york belli ed
eleganti che vendono cibo e vino dicono
di no ma parliamo di un'altra eccellenza
italiana abbandoniamo il cibo e andiamo
a parlare di moda
questo è quello che scrive la maggiore
rivista italiani moda il look con ri
friendly più glam direttamente dalle
passerelle della fall winter e vabbè
abbiamo capito che le stagioni non sono
più quelli di una volta ma spiegatemi
perché io devo chiamare una donna
opulenta così come se fosse una strada
di montagna nel grand canyon e non
formosa come sono formosa le nostre
veneri e le donne che vediamo nei nostri
ritratti rinascimentale perché così ma
si vergogni non sono che vi vogliamo
parlare di pubblicità anzi di
advertising
dunque questa è la pagina pubblicitaria
di una vettura renault in spagna e parla
spagnolo
questa è una pagina pubblicitaria della
medesima vettura in francia e parla
francese
questa è la stessa pagina in italia e
parla inglese ci sono due sole parole
italiane il primo
che cosa ci sta succedendo se perfino il
sindacato
dice torniamo alle nostre radici
chiamiamoci landini questo unions junior
le radici del sindacato italiano siamo
sicuri
ecco la cosa curiosa perché oltre due
italiani un italiano su due non si
spiaccica una parola d'inglese e 60 per
cento nel 2012 diciamo che sono il 58
quindi non sappiamo l'inglese non lo
sappiamo come paese e si vede
e qui c'è da sperare che le competenze
mediche del signore che ha compilato
dalla signora che ha compilato questo
modulo della sua siano superiori della
competenza linguistica
eppure ogni giorno per pigrizia per
distrazione per conformismo perché ci
sembra moderno perché siamo provinciali
usiamo una quantità di parole inglesi
non necessarie non profondamente
inserita nel tessuto della lingua
italiana puramente accessorie e inutili
diciamo col invece telefonata diciamo
location invece di posto ho sentito dire
il nazareno è la location che renzi ha
scelto per l'incontro la sede di un
partito una location diciamo competitore
compilation diciamo customer care day by
day negli uffici si può sentire dire
dobbiamo schedulare una conference call
per infanti uning della customer
satisfaction con la business unit quando
basterebbe dire dobbiamo chiamare a
pippo franco e gennaro per mettere a
posto questa faccenda del servizio
clienti perché poi la business unit è
sempre pippo franco e gennaro
l'intento è mai la palla non solo delle
imprese ma anche i media la pubblica
amministrazione il governo
noi abbiamo una legge dello stato che si
chiama jobs act e vi assicuro che il
fatto che si chiami jobs act non l'ha
resa più simpatica e ha obbligato gli
speaker dei telegiornali di giobatta che
è una roba che non esiste in natura
avremo fra un po una cassa in inglese
che non ci sarà più simpatica perché ha
un nome inglese ecco un paio di mesi fa
dopo l'uscita del marchio romano
io mi sono detta che dovevo fare
qualcosa comunicare è il mio mestiere ho
in mente due processi e strumenti che
possono essere efficaci ho pensato con i
ragazzi del mio ufficio di mettere in
piedi una iniziativa in rete per fare
sensibilizzazione militanza su questo
problema gratis e senza spendere un
soldo semplicemente mettendoci un po di
competenza di comunicazione dell'ufficio
è un po di energia questa petizione che
invitava le pubbliche amministrazioni il
governo le imprese i media a dirlo in
italiano era rivolta in prima istanza
all'accademia della crusca perché
facesse si facesse protagonista di quest
opera di sensibilizzazione ci
aspettavamo un discreto riscontro ma non
quello che è successo in meno di un mese
hanno firmato mettendoci nome cognome
indirizzo 70 mila persone hanno firmato
giovani anziani poliglotti e persone che
non spiaccicano l'inglese hanno firmato
lettori e studenti hanno firmato a
traduttori insegnante italiana
insegnanti d'inglese hanno firmato
splendidi professionisti hanno chiamato
pensionati hanno firmato italiani
all'estero dicendo che cosa aveva 100 la
nostra lingua e hanno firmato stranieri
hanno firmato da tutto il mondo da
singapore da gerusalemme dal perù dal
sudafrica e dal nord africa dal canada
ma culturale è una cosa commovente io ho
passato ore a guardare questo film che
crescevano e a leggere le motivazioni e
vorrei farvi vedere qualcuno l'italiano
è un diritto ma anche un dovere
siamo i nove loda fuffa se pensiamo
scorrettamente parliamo altrettanto
scorrettamente lavori in una pubblica
amministrazione aiuto firmo perché ho
studiato al liceo classico ma ora lavoro
con gli economisti lavoro nella moda ho
ricevuto una pressa di linz per un
happening di preview nei trent non credo
che ci andò un ottimo italiano e un
decente inglese sono assai meglio di uno
scadente ita inglese shisha e sappiamo
di che stiamo parlando
questa è una delle più strepitosa o un
nome straniero ma parli italiano di
cerci un gay fu da roma primo perché
inizia a mancarmi di decenza del nostro
linguaggio perché non vorrei mai dire
sentirvi al mio funerale che splendida
location
firmo per dante per montare per caproni
che del pavese per viaggiare di ben
carta sono stufo di sentire relatori che
non sanno dire the books on the table ma
si riempiono la bocca di company profile
e così succede
firmo perché non credo che chi dice
culla sia cool firmo perché ho senito
professori universitari che dicono
display ato invece che visualizzato sto
firmando perché non so l'inglese
primo perché desidero capire che cosa
dicono i politici che chiedono il mio
voto
era ora che qualcuno finalmente
prendesse questa iniziativa ha 85 anni
grazie per motori ecco vi dicevo un'eco
straordinaria e trasversale perché i
mezzi di comunicazione di massa hanno
preso questa cosa fatta a costo zero in
rete e l'hanno amplificata e questa
iniziativa è uscita in oltre 130
articoli sui giornali italiani con un
consenso fra smesso trasversale
inimmaginabile
ne hanno parlato insieme gramellini e
sel sulla stampa e sulla repubblica ma
la ripresa con grande plauso al secolo
d'italia e l'avvenire
ne ha parlato wired e ne ha parlato
vanity fair
ne ha parlato famiglia cristiana
ne ha parlato il mensile del touring ne
ha parlato oggi che è il direttore ha
fatto un editoriale una trasversalità e
che si è estesa tutto l'arco
costituzionale anche un po di qua un po
in là e che è andata in profondità dalle
testate più di nicchia e colte a quelle
più popolari e ai spesso nel grande
desiderio di riappropriarci con orgoglio
e consapevolezza della nostra lingua
questa cosa è finita nei telegiornali mi
è toccato ho toccato anche mettere mila
cicli e sul naso tg è stata ripresa
dalle radio sono stato intervistato da
una radio australiana da una dell'aned
ese ecco c'è bisogno di questo
e tutto questo è qualcosa che nasce
dalla consapevolezza di ognuno di noi
perchè la lingua è ciò che noi
costruiamo in ogni momento del nostro
parlare del nostro pensare e del nostro
scrivere ogni giorno e quindi l'appello
è teniamoci tutti stretti
l'italiano e mi ricordo
in conclusione qualche motivo per farlo
ad operai parole italiani aiuta a farsi
capire da tutti ed è un fatto di
democrazia perché farsi capire un fatto
di democrazia non ci vogliono regole non
ci vogliono divieti
ci vogliono buoni esempi e bisogna
chiedere alle istituzioni di dare il
buon esempio la nostra lingua
soprattutto è un valore è un fattore di
promozione
dobbiamo vendere la spenderla portarla
nel mondo perché ci rappresenta e sapere
più lingue
togliamo ogni dubbio è bellissimo
protegge anche il cervello sapere più di
una lingua ma chissà le lingue le usa
una alla volta
ita inglese oltretutto e l'abbiamo visto
è facile straparlare e quindi chi parla
come mangia parla meglio e poi è stato
citato leonardo nel primo degli
interventi di questa giornata
leonardo che definiva se stesso uomo
sanza lettera perché scriveva in volgare
cioè in italiano da sempre la struttura
la forma l'iridescenza della lingua
italiana ci aiuta esprimere la nostra
creatività se rinunciamo a esprimerci
nella nostra lingua
rinunciamo esprimere una delle
peculiarità delle flessuosità delle
magnifiche potenzialità della nostra
specifica creatività italiana che ha
radici nella sua lingua madre
e ancora se il nostro tessuto
linguistico è forte e solido possiamo
accogliere qualche termine straniero per
carità ma dobbiamo coniano dentro un
tessuto che non è esploso e logorato da
perdita di senso dovute a un eccesso di
termini stranieri mal usati perché vi
dico questo perché l'italiano siamo noi
gli italiani con la nostra identità le
nostre radici la nostra storia la nostra
apertura verso il mondo che passa dalle
nostre parole
grazie